I'm Jo and I work as an assistant practitioner in a CAM service in Lancashire. I bought and read Marianne's book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to accompany me while completing the clinical psychology training application. It proved to be really good company. I found it sparked ideas of how to build experience and skills, but more than that, it offered the chance to get lost in people's stories. It provided a timely reminder not to get so caught up in an environment. goal and to value and enjoy each job we fulfil along the way, because the work we do now is important and matters to those we sit alongside as well as ourselves. It also gave the reassurance that there are eclectic routes into clinical psychology, which is important for me as someone who's
我是乔，我在兰开夏郡的一家CAM服务机构担任助理执业人员。我购买并阅读了玛丽安的书《临床心理学家集体》，作为我完成临床心理学培训申请期间的伴侣。事实证明它确实是一个很好的陪伴。我发现它激发了我如何积累经验和技能的想法，但更重要的是，它提供了一个沉浸在他人故事中的机会。它及时提醒我，不要过分纠结于某个环境的目标，而是要去珍惜和享受我们在这一过程中完成的每一份工作，因为我们现在所做的工作非常重要，对我们身边的同行以及我们自己都意义重大。它还让我确信，通往临床心理学的途径是丰富多样的，这对我这个
had a meandering journey and not a typical route to the profession. I wholeheartedly recommend the book for both personal and professional reasons. Be prepared to put evening tasks on hold for a while though. because once you've started reading, it's tough to put it down. What if I told you that there is an access route into becoming a UK psychologist that most people don't know exists? A route that's even missed by qualified psychologists. Not knowing it nearly cost today's guest her dream career. In this episode, incoming trainee psychologist Esther Tio and I
走过一段曲折旅程、没有走传统职业路线的人来说非常重要。出于个人和职业原因，我全心全意推荐这本书。不过，请做好暂时搁置晚间任务的心理准备，因为一旦开始阅读，你就很难把它放下。如果我告诉你，有一种大多数人不知道存在的进入英国心理学家的途径呢？一条甚至连合格心理学家都会错过的途径。不知道这条途径差点让今天的嘉宾失去了她梦寐以求的职业。在本期节目中，即将入学的心理学实习生埃丝特·蒂奥和我
are taking a look at the BPS assessment of equivalence route and why sometimes the biggest barrier isn't your qualifications, it's knowing what's possible and combining it with your perseverance. Hi, welcome along to Psychology Actually. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. Today I'm joined by Esther Tio, an incoming trainee psychologist. Hi, Esther. Hi, hello.
将探讨英国心理学会（BPS）的同等学历评估途径，以及为什么最大的障碍往往不是你的资格证书，而是了解什么是可能的，并将其与你的坚持不懈结合起来。你好，欢迎收看《心理学其实》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天和我一起的是即将入学的心理学实习生埃丝特·蒂奥。你好，埃丝特。你好，哈喽。
Thank you so much for having me on. You're so welcome. We are recording on one of the UK's hottest ever days. So we are both in this and committed. But if anyone can hear our fans in the background, please do forgive us. We might melt without them. Thank you for pitching this episode to me.
非常感谢邀请我来参加。不用谢。我们录制节目时正值英国有史以来最热的日子之一。所以我们俩都在坚持，也都很有毅力。不过，如果有人能听到我们背景里的风扇声，请多多原谅。没有它们我们可能会融化。谢谢你向我推荐这一期节目。
It was not something I was aware of, but it's something that might well help so many people. Today we're talking about the GBC, which I always thought was something that you needed to have as part of your British cyclical. psychological society accredited undergraduate psychology degree or your conversion masters. Breaking news. That is not necessarily the case, is Esther. Over to you. Thank you. Yes. I did get in touch with Marian originally because people don't, yeah, people don't know about this process.
这不是我所知道的事情，但它很可能会帮助到很多人。今天我们讨论的是GBC，我以前一直认为这是你的英国心理学会认证的本科心理学学位或转换硕士学位的一部分。突发新闻。事实并非一定如此，埃丝特。交给你了。谢谢。是的。我最初确实联系了玛丽安，因为人们确实，是的，人们并不知道这个过程。
When I first went through this process, it was very, very, very hard to find reliable information, even on the kind of official VPS websites. I tried to find advice online in the forums and no one had really heard of it or gone through it successfully, so it's hard to get good advice. So this process is a process called assessment of equivalence, and it's also kind of known as the special case assessment. It's something that happens online on the BPS website through a portal.
当我第一次经历这个过程时，要找到可靠的信息非常非常难，即使在官方的BPS网站上也是如此。我试图在论坛上寻找在线建议，但没有人真正听说过它或成功经历过它，所以很难得到好的建议。所以这个过程被称为同等学历评估过程，它也被称为特殊情况评估。这是在BPS网站上通过一个门户在线进行的事情。
It's fairly inexpensive. It costs about 50 or 60 pounds to apply. It takes a couple of weeks for them to turn it around, involves you submitting lots of evidence about your academic history and your academic experience, for example, your transcripts and all your paperwork. It's quite detailed. And then they assess it to see whether you have enough psychology content in your studies to classify as equivalent to a psychology degree. great so if anyone's watching or listening to this and they're like what is the gbc what is the gbr we've kind of had a bit of a chat about this that well we're not really sure other than that it's a kind of stamp of approval that says that a student or a graduate has had enough breadth and depth of clinically relevant helpful psychology informed content for them to be able to thrive, hopefully, and do well in an applied psychology profession. And that would include, in the UK, clinical psychology, counselling psychology, forensic psychology, sport and exercise, educational, organisation, occupational. I think that's covered them all. I might have
它相当便宜。申请费用约为50或60英镑。他们需要几周的时间来处理，需要你提交大量关于你的学术历史和学术经验的证据，例如你的成绩单和所有的文件。这非常详细。然后他们对其进行评估，以查看你的学习中是否有足够的心理学内容，是否可以归类为相当于心理学学位。太棒了，所以如果任何人正在观看或收听这个节目，并且他们觉得什么是GBC，什么是GBR，我们之前已经讨论过这个，我们其实并不确定，除了它是一种批准印章，表明学生或毕业生已经掌握了足够广度和深度的、临床相关的、有帮助的、以心理学为依据的内容，以便他们能够蓬勃发展，希望在应用心理学行业中做得很好。在英国，这将包括临床心理学、咨询心理学、法医心理学、运动与锻炼、教育、组织、职业。我想我已经把它们都涵盖了。我可能
forgotten one and I'm sorry if you're listening or you're like, yes, you have, Marianne. But that is, like, it's the benchmark, isn't it? And sometimes people will do a retraining master. They might have done, I don't know, accountancy or nursing or something as their even teaching as their undergraduate degree. And then you're like, oh, I've discovered psychology and they'll do the conversion. And hopefully that will then have that BPS, GBC, or in my days, it was GBR, which was graduate basis for registration. That changed in 2009. But that's what, if you know, if you're listening to this as a much earlier applicant, maybe you're doing your A levels, you're considering about your options, you're considering maybe retraining, before you've even applied to a course.
漏掉了一个，如果你正在收听或者觉得“是的，你漏掉了，玛丽安”，我向你道歉。但这就是基准，不是吗？有时人们会攻读再培训硕士学位。他们可能把会计、护理甚至教学作为本科学位。然后你会想，“哦，我发现了心理学”，他们就会做转换。希望这样就会有BPS的GBC，或者在我那个年代，它是GBR，也就是注册研究生基础。这在2009年改变了。但如果你以一个更早的申请者的身份收听这个节目，也许你正在读A-Level，正在考虑你的选择，正在考虑也许在申请课程之前进行再培训。
If you know you want to go down one of the HCP practitioner psychologist routes, you will need this GBC. That's correct, isn't it? Esther? Yes, yeah, absolutely. Amazing. So, I mean, life can happen, can't it? I, through the very skin of my teeth, managed to get my GBR, which would now be GBC, in place by the end of my undergraduate psychology degree. But I originally went to university to do a different course and then transferred to psychology. So I didn't necessarily pick the course for psychology. And others might be in that position where it's a little bit accidental, but then you get to the end of your study.
如果你知道你想沿着HCP职业心理学家的路线走下去，你将需要这个GBC。对吧，埃丝特？是的，是的，完全正确。太棒了。所以，生活总是充满了意外，不是吗？我千钧一发，在本科心理学学位结束时拿到了我的GBR（现在是GBC）。但我最初去大学是读另一门课程，然后转到心理学的。所以我并不一定是为了心理学而选择这门课程的。其他人也可能处于这种偶然的状态，但当你完成学业时。
It's not a cheap thing. Or you get to the end of your master's. Again, not cheap in terms of outlay, not cheap in terms of time spent, stress, trying to fit all that into your life. And then you're like, are you kidding me? I've got to do another degree or I've got to do another one or two year conversion to get my GBC. Oh, I don't know if I've got that in me. So maybe I'll end up just doing a PhD or something like that, which isn't really my passion. It isn't what I want. could you tell us a little bit about how you ended up in the position where you didn't have your GBC from the BPS? Absolutely, yeah, thank you. So originally I went and did neuroscience as my undergrad.
这不是一件便宜的事。或者当你完成硕士学位时。同样，从投入来看并不便宜，从花费的时间、压力、试图将所有这些融入你的生活来看也不便宜。然后你会想：你在开玩笑吗？我得再读一个学位，或者我得再读一两年转换课程来获得我的GBC。哦，我不知道我有没有这个精力。所以也许我最终只会去读个博士什么的，但这并不是我的激情所在。这不是我想要的。你能给我们讲讲你是怎么陷入没有BPS的GBC的境地的吗？当然，谢谢。所以最初我去读了神经科学作为我的本科。
I thought that this was really, really, really kind of me and set for life. But obviously at that age, who's to say, who's to know and things change. And so I did really love that degree. I loved the neuroscience. I loved thinking about the brain and how. how it drives behaviour. But after those years, I kind of grew a bit weary and I no longer cared about proteins. I didn't care about them. I didn't care about cells. I didn't care about proteins and I loved the part about behavior and I love the part about psychology. So that motivated me to go
我觉得这真的非常非常适合我，而且生活有着落了。但显然在那个年纪，谁能说得准，谁又能知道呢，事情是会变化的。所以我真的很喜欢那个学位。我喜欢神经科学。我喜欢思考大脑以及它是如何驱动行为的。但在那些年之后，我开始觉得有些疲惫，我不再关心蛋白质了。我不在乎它们。我不在乎细胞。我不在乎蛋白质，但我喜欢关于行为的部分，我喜欢心理学的部分。所以这促使我去
into a Masters of Developmental Neuroscience and Psychopathology and this had a really kind of really heavy psychology emphasis. Unfortunately, that degree also wasn't accredited. So then I was ended up with both degrees unaccredited. Still not really sure that I wanted to do a psychology doctorate at all, or that I wanted GBC, and thought maybe I would want to kind of stay in research. So then went into a few jobs and did a research assistant position for a while. And I did that for about three years. And along the three years, people were kind of encouraging me, what's next, what's next? And the natural route is a PhD in research, which didn't really feel right to me. It was missing something huge and it was missing the clinical contact and that kind of really
攻读发展神经科学与心理病理学硕士学位，这个学位有非常非常重的心理学侧重点。不幸的是，那个学位也没有获得认证。所以我最终拿到了两个未获认证的学位。仍然不确定我是否真的想攻读心理学博士学位，或者我是否想要GBC，并认为也许我想留在研究领域。然后我从事了几份工作，做了一段时间的研究助理。我做了大约三年。在这三年里，人们一直在鼓励我，下一步是什么，下一步是什么？自然的路线是研究领域的博士学位，这对我来说感觉不太对劲。它缺少了极其重要的一点，那就是缺少临床接触和那种真正
meaningful contact for me. And I did love a lot about it and I wasn't ready to kind of give it up. And that's when a lot of people, a lot of careers advisors, a lot of internet searches told me clinical psychology sounds really perfect for you. But there was this huge barrier, the huge barrier that. that I couldn't do it without a conversion masters, which is a really, it's great that it exists. It's great that people can transition parts of their life
对我有意义的接触。我确实很喜欢它的很多方面，我还没准备好放弃它。就在那时，很多人，很多职业顾问，很多互联网搜索告诉我，临床心理学听起来对你来说非常完美。但这里有一个巨大的障碍，这个巨大的障碍就是没有转换硕士学位我就做不到，转换硕士学位确实很好，它存在是件好事。人们可以过渡他们生活的一部分，
where they can transition into this field. At the time, I couldn't afford to do this, nor could I fit this in my life, and I'd just done another master's, and it felt like a really, really big barrier, especially since my studies since I could remember, were really psychology heavy. And so it felt like such a shame to then pay all this money
他们可以过渡到这个领域。当时我买不起，也无法将其融入我的生活，我刚刚完成了另一个硕士学位，这感觉像是一个非常非常大的障碍，尤其是自从我记事起我的学习就一直非常侧重于心理学。因此，花所有这些钱
and do this whole conversion masters when I could guarantee that I've covered really, really, really quite a lot of it. So that's how I stumbled upon this particular process. A little embarrassing actually, but the way that I found out about it was I asked Chat Chabutee, I said,
并完成整个转换硕士学位，而我本可以保证我已经涵盖了非常非常相当多的内容，这真是一种遗憾。这就是我偶然发现这个特定过程的原因。其实有点尴尬，但我发现它的方式是我问了Chat Chabutee，我说，
I've tried everything, I have no idea what to do with my life, just tell me what to do. And it said, I think that clinical psychology sounds perfect for you, which point I said, you idiot, I can't do that. And it said, actually, have you heard of this process? This assessment of equivalence process, which I'd never heard of. I'd never spoken to anyone who had heard of it.
我尝试了一切，我不知道我的生活该怎么办，只管告诉我该怎么做。它说，我觉得临床心理学听起来对你很完美。这时我说，你个笨蛋，我做不到。然后它说，其实，你听说过这个过程吗？这个同等学历评估过程，我以前从未听说过。我从未和任何听说过它的人交谈过。
And it was really, really helpful, actually, at taking me through this process and what was actually needed. I think that the information is, for some reason or another, very inaccessible. One of the biggest reasons I reached out to you, Marion, is because I'd really like to make this information a bit more accessible. I've seen people on the forums on Facebook. and things, asking similar questions, especially maybe people with abroad degrees, and lots of people, very, very well-meaning and sometimes even qualified practitioners saying, I'm really sorry, but this is the only way you have to do a conversion course. Yeah, I think anyone working in an NHS service already qualified should definitely know about
事实上，它在带我了解这个过程以及实际需要什么方面真的非常非常有帮助。我认为由于某种原因，这些信息非常难以获取。我联系你玛丽安的最大原因之一，是因为我真的很想让这些信息更容易获取。我在Facebook等论坛上看到人们
this because people will ask them. And people will often come to me and say, actually I'm already a qualified psychologist in India or in another country and, you know, I don't have this GBC. What can I do? And my answer would always been before. There's no other way around it. But actually, there is. This is a really, really important community message. So thank you, Esther. And you've gone one step beyond what is helpful because you've put together a really, beautiful guide. Tell us about your guide, Esther. Yeah, thank you. I thought that because this process is inaccessible enough as it is, it's hard to find reliable information. I personally really like information to be nice and visual and clear. So I've put together a kind of leaflet or
和类似的东西，问类似的问题，尤其是可能有国外学位的人，很多人，非常非常善意，有时甚至是合格的从业人员说，我真的很抱歉，但这是唯一的途径，你必须参加转换课程。是的，我认为任何在NHS服务中工作且已经合格的人绝对应该了解
just PDF that visualises what is the GBC, what is the process that it takes to get the assessment of equivalents. How long does it take? What documents do you need? Who could be eligible? Kind of what you'd want to know. It is written on the document, but a lot of this because information is quite scarce out there, it is based on my personal experience. Some of the information, especially about kind of what documents you actually need. I kind of just made it up because it said supporting documents and so here it didn't say, watch ones. So I kind of just uploaded everything and anything I could think of that they wanted. And it worked. So that's what I put on there. But it's not exactly official guidance at that
这个，因为人们会问他们。人们经常来找我说，其实我已经是一名在印度或其他国家合格的心理学家了，你知道，我没有这个GBC。我能做什么？我以前的回答总是：没有别的办法。但实际上，这是有的。这是一个非常非常重要的社区信息，所以谢谢你，埃丝特。而且你做的事情比有帮助的还要多一步，因为你制作了一份非常精美的指南。给我们讲讲你的指南吧，埃丝特。好的，谢谢。我认为因为这个过程本身就很难获取，很难找到可靠的信息。我个人真的很喜欢信息既美观又视觉化且清晰。所以我整理了一份传单或者
part, but hopefully will be helpful to other people in similar positions. So yet, people can get hold of this guide. It's totally free. And you can get hold of it by going to gtps.cartra.com forward slash BPS hyphen guide. There will, of course, be details in the show notes and will be on screen for YouTube as well. What do you wish you'd known then, Esther? be, I don't know, let's go seven years ago, what would have been helpful? Would you have done anything different or do you actually feel that you are going to be a better incoming trainee because of the slightly diverse experiences and the journey you've had? Yeah, thank you for asking. I think that I think I would have done things quite notably differently. I would have really
仅仅是PDF，它形象化了什么是GBC，获得同等学历评估需要什么过程。需要多长时间？你需要什么文件？谁有资格？基本上是你想要了解的内容。文件上写着，但由于很多信息在外面相当稀缺，它是基于我的个人经验。有些信息，特别是关于你实际需要什么文件的信息。我差不多就是编造出来的，因为它说支持文件，但这里没有说看哪些。所以我差不多上传了我能想到的他们想要的每一件事和任何东西。而且成功了。这就是我放在那里的东西。但它并不完全是官方指导
focused a bit earlier on clinical experience rather than research experience. I think that was my kind of big barrier and big gap. I thought it would be more a barrier, but I managed to get in the first time, which I really, really wasn't expecting. I definitely would have chosen a master's program that was accredited because though I did manage to do this process, there was quite a few panicky moments in between,
部分，但希望对处于类似情况的其他人有所帮助。所以是的，人们可以拿到这份指南。它是完全免费的。你可以通过访问gtps.cartra.com斜杠BPS连字符guide来获取。节目笔记中当然会有详细信息，YouTube屏幕上也会显示。埃丝特，你希望当时知道些什么？比方说，我不知道，我们回到七年前，什么会有所帮助？你会做任何不同的事情吗，或者你其实觉得因为你稍微多样化的经历和走过的旅程，你将成为一个更好的准实习生？是的，谢谢你的提问。我想我会做一些相当显著不同的事情。我真的会
and I actually didn't originally get given this membership that I granted the GBC. I applied originally. I waited, and I waited, and I waited, and I followed up, and I had an email to say, sorry, you've been completely rejected. It said, your degrees aren't accredited, and you'll have to do the conversion course.
更早一点专注于临床经验而不是研究经验。我认为那是我的巨大障碍和巨大差距。我以为这会是一个更大的障碍，但我第一次就成功进入了，这真是我完全没有料到的。我绝对会选择一个获得认证的硕士项目，因为虽然我确实成功完成了这个过程，但中间有相当多的恐慌时刻，
Here's the link to the conversion course, at which point I remember being on holiday, and I thought, oh, no, I found a glimmer of hope. I really attached onto this, thought, this is a perfect career for me. Surely at some point I will get this, either I thought I would get it granted, because I had really, really quite a significant psychology content in my undergrad and master, especially my masters.
而且我最初其实并没有获得授予GBC的这个会员资格。我最初申请了。我等啊，等啊，等啊，我跟进了，我收到了一封电子邮件，上面说，对不起，你被完全拒绝了。上面说，你的学位没有获得认证，你将不得不参加转换课程。
And I thought maybe what they could have said is an option is they could have said, actually these are the top-up modules you have to do from the conversion course, you don't have to do the entire thing, which I also would have been very happy with. But instead they said you're completely rejected. I took a couple of weeks and mourned this and was really upset. And then, again, quite uncharacteristically, I sent this back to Chachyby. and said, you said I had a shot. You should I said I had a shot. Why do you say that? You've got my hopes up. And it said, oh, I'm sorry. I really thought you had a shot. But also, it seems a bit
这里是转换课程的链接，当时我记得正在度假，我想，哦，不，我找到了一丝希望。我真的紧紧抓住这一点，心想，这是我完美的职业。肯定在某个时候我会得到这个，要么我认为我会得到批准，因为我的本科和硕士，尤其是我的硕士，有非常非常大量的心理学内容。
interesting that this email seems to be from the wrong person. It seems to be from the admissions team rather than the membership team. And I thought, huh, yeah, actually now you say it. The email does sound a bit weird because it says, so your degrees aren't accredited, rather than we've processed everything you sent in, because I sent in so much. And, And so I replied, and I said, I replied to the email, and I said, could someone kind of take another look at this? I'm just wondering if it's gone to the right team. This is your criteria.
我想也许他们可以说的一个选择是，他们可以说，实际上这些是你必须从转换课程中完成的补修模块，你不必完成整个课程，这也是我非常乐意接受的。但相反，他们说你被完全拒绝了。我花了几周时间为此哀悼，真的很沮丧。然后，同样很不寻常的是，我把这个发回给了Chachyby。并说，你说我有机会的。你应该我说我有机会的。你为什么这么说？你让我燃起了希望。然后它说，哦，我很抱歉。我真的以为你有机会。而且，这似乎有点
This is how I need it. I'm a bit confused about what's happening here. And again, I had no response. I had no response for weeks and weeks and weeks. And really uncharacteristically, I just called. I just thought, no, this is not happening. And I called, and I called again, I called every day until I had a response. So then eventually I got through to something.
这就是我所需要的。我对这里发生的事情有点困惑。而且再次重申，我没有得到任何回复。我连续好几个星期都没有收到任何回复。我一反常态地直接打了电话。我当时想，不，绝不能这样。于是我打了电话，又打了一遍，我每天都打，直到有了回应。最终我终于联系上了相关人员。
someone who looked over it again and said, yeah, actually, this went to the wrong team, and they reposted it, and but in an hour I got an email saying you've been granted the entire thing, the accreditation. So that was a really crazy day for me. But back to the original question, I think one of the things that I would have done differently is I would have been a bit more proactive from the start, and I would have been quite vigilant because I don't think a lot of people know about this route, I don't think it's used that often. And so I don't think that infrastructure is there really for it a lot of the time. And I think that when you enter all your details, the portal seems to be quite similar for quite a lot of services that they offer. So I think
有人重新审视了这件事并说，是的，实际上这被分到了错误的团队，他们重新发布了它。仅仅过了一个小时，我就收到了一封电子邮件，说我获得了全部的认证。对当时的我和我来说，那真是疯狂的一天。但回到最初的问题，我认为我本可以采取的一种不同做法是，从一开始就更具主动性，而且要非常警惕，因为我认为很多人并不了解这条途径，它似乎也不常用。因此，很多时候我认为相应的配套机制并不健全。而且我觉得当你输入所有详细信息时，他们提供的许多服务的门户网站看起来都非常相似。所以我想
one of the biggest things is just being really proactive, really clear with your application. Why am I sending this in? What am I looking for? Really, really, really so no one can miss it. Just so clearly, I'm going for the assessment of equivalents. This is where I want this application to be sent. This is the team I want it to be. sent to, just so there's no slip-ups. And then I guess just that piece of advice of even if you do get an initial rejection, just really do check, really do check because it could be the difference between following this career and then completely giving up because that's the way it was for me.
最重要的事情之一就是保持高度主动，让你的申请材料非常清晰。我为什么要提交这个？我在寻找什么？一定要清清楚楚，这样任何人都不会漏看。非常明确地写明：我正在申请同等学历评估。这就是我希望发送这份申请的地方。这就是我希望发送到的团队，这样才不会出现任何差错。然后我想，那就是一个建议：即使你真的收到了最初的拒绝，也一定要去核对，一定要去核对，因为这可能会决定你是选择这条职业道路还是彻底放弃，因为我当时的情况就是这样。
It was just a call away for me. So, yeah. Oh, Esther. I mean, well done on your perseverance. But also that is a real power dynamic, isn't it? You know, computer says no. But yeah, when you first said, oh, you don't meet, you don't have the criteria, it doesn't meet. I thought, well, that's the point.
对我来说，只需一个电话就能解决。所以，是的。哦，埃丝特。我是说，祝贺你的坚持不懈。但这也是一种真实的权力动态，不是吗？你知道，电脑说不行。但是，当你最初听到“哦，你不符合，你不具备条件，这不符合要求”时，我想，这正是问题的关键。
So, but, you know, often we'll just see it saying no and be like, oh, well, I tried. But that could have cost you thousands and thousands of pounds and meant that you were sitting alongside people that were retraining from biology or retraining from being a maths teacher who were learning psychology concepts for the first time. You're shoulder by shoulder thinking, I'm really like being here. and I really want this GPC, but I do know this already. That would have been really frustrating and probably quite angry making. Definitely, definitely.
所以，你知道，通常我们看到“拒绝”就会说，“好吧，我试过了”。但那可能会让你花费成千上万英镑，并意味着你将和那些从生物学或数学老师转型而来、第一次学习心理学概念的人坐在一起。你肩并肩地坐着，心想，我真的很喜欢这里，我真的非常想要这个GPC，但我其实已经懂这些了。那会非常令人沮丧，而且可能会让人相当气愤。绝对是的，绝对是的。
And I think that there was a stage of reflection for me where I thought, if this is a big enough barrier for me, that I wouldn't do that for a year or two, then am I really committed enough? And is this really for me? Because I saw around me a lot of people going for this, they're very, very, very committed. They're committed with their time, their efforts, their money, everything. And so there was a period where I thought, well, maybe I don't want it enough if that is the case, because I'm not willing to do all of this, even though I really couldn't afford to do that at the time.
并且我认为对我来说有一个反思的阶段，我当时想，如果这是一个对我都构成了这么大障碍、让我一两年都不愿去做的难关，那我真的是否足够投入呢？这真的适合我吗？因为我看到周围有很多人都在争取这个，他们非常非常非常投入。他们投入了时间、精力、金钱以及一切。因此曾有一段时间我想，如果情况真是这样，也许我并没有那么渴望，因为我并不愿意付出这一切，尽管我当时确实承担不起这些成本。
But so I'm very, very, very grateful that that's something that is available for people, but that is not something that I had to go through because, as you said, it would have been really frustrating. My master's course in particular was in the psychology department of UCL. So every one of my taught and examined modules was from the psychology department. department and it had more psychoanalysis in it than it did neuroscience, even though it's called neuroscience. It just was quite a small course, so it wasn't accredited. I have since got in touch with the course to say that this is something that I have experienced and if people are in similar situations with this particular course because it does have a phenomenal amount of psychology in it, that it's an option. Again, because I just really care about people knowing about
不过，我非常非常非常感激有这样一种途径可以供人们选择，但我也很高兴这并不是我最终必须经历的，因为正如你所说，那确实会非常令人沮丧。我的硕士课程特别是在UCL的心理学系。因此，我的每一门授课和考核模块都来自心理学系。虽然它被称为神经科学，但其中包含的精神分析内容甚至多于神经科学。只是因为课程规模较小，所以没有获得认证。我此后曾与该课程部门取得联系，说明了我的这段经历，如果有人因为这门特殊的课程而处于类似的境况中——因为它确实包含了惊人数量的心理学内容——这也可以作为一个选项。再次强调，因为我真的很在意人们能够了解
this process. Yeah, I think you make a really valid point. You've got to be able to be mindful of how much emotional energy you've got left in the tank and you've already done your undergrad you've already done your masters just before we hit record we was talking about me having some love in my heart to potentially get a cat but it doesn't mean I want a whole other child because I've already got two of those I haven't got the energy left in me to be pregnant and birth and raise that child in the very early years I haven't got that in me like and I think it's similar you've got to be mindful of of what you want to do and what feels like that's a reasonable thing that you can manage. So I love that you got the result that you did.
这个流程。是的，我觉得你提出了一个非常中肯的观点。你必须能够注意到自己心中还剩多少情感能量，而且你已经完成了本科，也已经完成了硕士。就在我们点击录音之前，我们还在聊我有养只猫的念头，但这并不意味着我想再要一个完整的孩子，因为我已经有两个了。我没有多余的精力去怀孕、生子并在最初几年抚养那个孩子，我没有这种精力。我认为这很相似，你必须注意你想做什么，以及什么才是你觉得合理且能够应付的事情。所以我很高兴你能得到那样的结果。
And it came in a really timely manner, didn't it? Because it allowed you to then apply for the doctorate in a quite speedy way. Very, too speedy, actually, yes. So the timeline was that I did get my rejection and had to follow up, but I think I left it quite a long time because I did go into this kind of period of reflection. I went to this period of, well, maybe this isn't for me if I'm not willing to do a whole conversion masters. And then I don't know what switched one day. And I just, I was like, no, this is not happening? I can't let this happen to me. So I did just call every day. And I think
而且结果来得非常及时，不是吗？因为它让你能够以相当快的方式去申请博士项目。实际上，太快了，是的。时间线是这样的：我确实收到了拒绝信并不得不跟进，但我认为我搁置了相当长的一段时间，因为我进入了那种反思期。我进入了这样一个阶段：“好吧，如果我不愿意去读一个完整的转换硕士，也许这并不适合我。”然后我不知道哪一天突然想通了。我当时就想，不，这绝不能发生！我怎么能让这种事发生在我身上？所以我确实每天都打电话。我想
that's when I realized, no, I really, really care about this. I really want to do this is something that I'm really passionate about. I'm not a particularly assertive person at all. I don't know where that came from at all. But I think does show that I really did care about this. So I got the eventual exemption confirmation about a week before the deadline to apply that cycle for the declin side. And though it was a panic, I think, to get things together, I know everyone says this, but I really didn't expect to get in. So I think I was using it as a kind of practice and what do I have and what do I need? What does this process look like? I really dedicated myself to it to a week, which actually came, and this is a whole other story, but it actually came in a time where
也就是在那时我意识到，不，我真的、真的很在乎这个。我真的想做这件事，这是我真正充满热情的事。我根本不是一个特别自信的人。我真不知道那种勇气是从哪里来的。但这确实表明我真的很在乎这件事。所以我在那轮申请临床博士截止日期前大约一周，最终收到了豁免确认。尽管把事情凑齐是一场手忙脚乱的恐慌，我知道每个人都会这么说，但我当时真的没指望能被录取。所以我想我只是把它当成一种练习：我有什么？我需要什么？这个流程是什么样的？我真的全身心投入了一个星期。其实，说来话长，那件事发生在一个
I had, when I received the rejection, I thought, okay, well, I guess I'll go down to the research route and I'll apply to research PhDs and ended up getting one. And it was at the stage where I either confirm and really go for it and apply for funding with this one with the same deadline, or I completely ditch it because I can't do both at the same time, or I completely ditch it and I go for this application, kind of knowing that I probably won't get in this year or maybe even the following year. and so I thought I'm going to do it now that I know that this is an option for me even thinking about this other route just feels
当我收到拒绝信时，我想，好吧，我想我还是走研究路线去申请研究型博士吧，结果还真拿到一个。当时的情况是，要么我确认并全力以赴，在同一个截止日期前用这个申请去争取资助，要么我彻底放弃它，因为我无法同时做两件事。或者我彻底放弃它，去申请那个临床博士，尽管心里清楚今年甚至明年可能都进不去。所以我当时想，既然我知道这是我的一个选项，我还是现在就去做吧。甚至只是去考虑另一条路线，我都觉得
it just doesn't feel right and it didn't feel me with the same passion at all and I thought even if this takes me a couple of years to get in then I'd still rather do that and I still prefer the long term and the career path of this one
感觉就是不对劲，而且完全无法带给我同样的热情。我想，即使这需要我花上好几年才能考上，我仍然宁愿那样做，我依然更偏爱长远的发展以及这条职业道路。
so then I had to pull out of that one in the same week as trying to pull together the application for the Deacon and luckily I was surrounded by very, very, very supportive people, including both my references, for example, my professor at the time, very, very, very supportive. So I was very lucky in that way that people were willing to kind of really band together and do something last minute and managed to pull something together just for the deadline. And so that was an interesting, stressful week,
所以，我不得不在准备临床博士申请的同一周里退掉那个研究职位。幸运的是，我身边环绕着非常、非常、非常支持我的人，包括我的两封推荐信的撰写人，比如我当时的教授，都给予了我极大、极大、极大支持。所以在这一点上我很幸运，大家愿意真正团结起来，在最后一分钟做点什么，并在截止日期前成功把材料拼凑了出来。所以那是一个有趣又压力重重的星期，
almost as kind of panicking and sweaty as this week, but eventually got it in. Yeah. Yeah, probably similarly lack of sleep due to the incredible heat we're experiencing at the moment. But I think, you know, what this really speaks to is, is time and time again in the clinical psychologist collective book. People talk about tenacity, patience, perseverance, but also you have to have that unwavering belief that this is for you. And I think people who maybe are no less good applicants, but don't have that doggie determination, are more likely to go and do other routes or to say, actually, no, I'm not doing this. But if you have that, you, you're you are just by percentages more likely to get, you know, what you want ultimately.
几乎和这星期一样令人恐慌和汗流浃背，但最终还是交上去了。是的。是的，可能同样是因为我们目前经历的酷暑而导致睡眠不足。但我认为，这真正说明的一点是，在《临床心理学家集体》这本书中，一次又一次地，人们谈到了坚韧、耐心、毅力，但同时你也必须拥有那份坚定不移的信念，即这正是为你准备的。我认为，那些申请条件并不逊色但缺乏这种顽强决心的申请者，更有可能去选择其他途径，或者说“好吧，不，我不干了”。但如果你拥有这种信念，从概率上讲，你更有可能最终得到你想要的东西。
And you're a fine example of it, Esther. Thank you. Yeah, I think that at that stage of my life, I think I'm really trying to push myself to kind of go for things and really kind of say, why not, why not this and why not that? And that's something I've been really working on. I think that I guess this big fear of failure or fear of rejection. is a really, really big one. And so I think that can and has put me off a lot of things. But I think it was like kind of nothing to lose, just go for it sort of attitude that I think really, really, really has pulled through to me and been quite life-changing in this case.
而你就是一个极好的例子，埃斯特。谢谢你。是的，我认为在我生命的那个阶段，我真的很想逼自己去尝试各种事情，并真正地去说：为什么不呢，为什么不选这个，为什么不选那个？这也是我一直在努力做的事情。我认为，对失败的巨大恐惧或对被拒绝的恐惧，确实是一个非常、非常大的阻碍。因此我认为这可能会、并且也确实让我对很多事情退避三舍。但我认为，那种“反正没有什么可失去的，放手去干吧”的态度，确实真正地、真正地帮我度过了难关，并在这种情况下改变了人生。
Yeah, and this is clearly an authentic path for you. It's what lights you up. It's what lights me up. Like, I couldn't imagine doing anything different. Even today, as I was out and about, I was chatting to a really lovely older guy in the street because I talk to strangers. It's what I do. He said he's 86, he was out for a walk, and I was like, it's really, really hot. Make sure that you're drinking enough. And we had a little chat, and then we kind of parted ways. And then he shouted after me, he said, by the way, my name's, you know, it would be nice to chat to you in future. And I just, you know, probably that's partly my personality as well.
是的，这显然是一条属于你的真实道路。这是点亮你的东西。这也是点亮我的东西。就像，我无法想象去做任何其他不同的事情。甚至在今天，当我在外面闲逛时，我和街上一个非常可爱的老爷爷聊了天，因为我喜欢和陌生人聊天。这就是我的作风。他说他86岁了，出来散步。我说天气真的、真的很热，一定要确保喝足够的水。我们简单聊了一会儿，然后就各走各的路了。接着他在后面喊我，说：“顺便说一句，我叫什么名字，以后能和你聊聊就好了。”我只是觉得，可能这部分也是因为我的个性吧。
But I believe in using yourself as an intervention and trying to be something that makes a difference. Because I'm confident probably nobody else spoke to him out and about. and obviously probably often doesn't because of the response that I got. And what we do matters, but it has to feel authentic to you. And clearly, maybe you don't talk to strangers in the streets, especially if you live in London, but, you know, you are clearly driven to this profession and lit up by it. I actually, it's something I love to do, actually.
但我坚信将自己作为一种干预手段，并努力成为一个能带来改变的人。因为我敢肯定，可能没有其他人跟他搭过话。显然由于我得到的反馈，他平时可能经常没有这种交流。我们所做的事情很重要，但它必须对你而言感觉是真实的。显然，也许你不会在街上和陌生人聊天，特别是如果你住在伦敦的话；但无论如何，你显然是被这个职业所驱动，并被它点亮。实际上，这正是我喜欢做的事情。
I love talking to strangers, much to my partner's demise and my friend's demise, because I love it and I think it's one of my favorite things, I guess, about myself, is that that's something I'm not afraid to do and something I love. And I think some of my favorite conversations I've ever had in my life has happened with strangers on the train. And I think one of the biggest gifts of, I guess, being in the mental health space. Obviously, when you're kind of making small talk with someone or first getting to know someone, it does come up and you say, I work in the mental health space and I used to work in
我喜欢和陌生人聊天，尽管这常常让我伴侣和朋友感到抓狂，因为我太喜欢了。我想这也是我自己最喜欢我自己的地方之一——我不害怕这样做，而且我热爱这样做。我认为我一生中经历过的一些最喜欢的对话，都是在火车上和陌生人发生的。而且我认为，身处心理健康领域最大的礼物之一，显然当你在和某人进行闲聊或刚开始了解某人时，这个话题自然会出现，你会说：“我在心理健康领域工作，我以前在……”
with people with treatment-resistant depression and things like psychedelic treatments and stuff and lots of things that kind of generate a lot of conversation. And you do find that, and I don't know whether you find the same thing, that people do just kind of really open up and disclose, and you do skip so many stages of small talk, which I don't know how to do that either. So that really works for me. And I think I've had the most enriching conversations of my life with strangers, and I love it too.
与患有治疗抵抗性抑郁症的人以及诸如迷幻治疗之类的事情打交道，还有很多能够引发大量对话的事情。你会发现——我不知道你是否也有同感——人们确实会敞开心扉并向你吐露心声，你可以跳过大量的闲聊阶段，而我也并不会闲聊。所以这对我非常管用。我想我一生中最丰富多彩的对话都是和陌生人进行的，我也很喜欢这样。
I absolutely agree. I think if you and I ever meet in person, watch out well because there'll be some really incredible conversations. But yeah, like I feel like I've had, it might sound a bit narcissistic, but I've had almost unique place to find people in the right time, in the right space to potentially change their lives. You know, even in Uber's, end up doing like mini life coaching sessions where they go off and someone even said, right, I'm going to look at conversion masters because I've always wanted to do this. and, you know, off the back of being in a car with me for 20 minutes, potentially changes this guy's life. And I love the power of the potential of what you can do when you're not even striving for anything. There's no goal there.
我绝对同意。我想如果你和我哪天能在现实中见面，那可得小心了，因为肯定会有一些非常不可思议的对话。但是，是的，我觉得我拥有——这听起来可能有点自恋——一个几乎独一无二的位置，能够在正确的时间、正确的空间遇到合适的人，并有可能改变他们的人生。你知道，甚至在优步上，我最终也会进行迷迷你人生教练课程，他们下车后，甚至有人说：“好，我要去看看转换硕士课程，因为我一直想这么做。”你知道的，仅仅因为和我同乘一辆车20分钟，就可能改变了这个家伙的人生。我热爱当你甚至没有刻意追求什么时，你所能做事情的潜能和力量。那里没有任何目标。
It's just that connection, seeing another person where they're at, and being curious. That's what I love. Yeah, absolutely, I agree. There's just, there's a lot to learn. There's a lot to learn from people. I agree. Thank you so much for your time.
只有那种连接，看到另一个人身处何地，并保持好奇心。这就是我所热爱的。是的，绝对地，我同意。这里有很多东西要学。有很多东西可以从人们身上学习。我同意。非常感谢你抽出时间。
Thank you for reaching out to me and pitching this episode. I think it's going to be helpful for so many people. There's details in the show notes and on screen about how people can access that guide. Thank you for putting it together because, as I said, it's honestly the most beautiful guide I've ever seen. So well done. Thanks again for your time, Esther. Thank you so much. Thanks.
谢谢你联系我并推介这一期节目。我想这会对非常多的人有所帮助。节目简介和屏幕上都有关于人们如何获取该指南的详细信息。谢谢你把它整理出来，因为正如我所说，这老实说是我见过的最漂亮的指南。干得好。再次感谢你抽出时间，埃斯特。非常感谢。谢谢。
Thank you so much to my guest, Esther Tio. I did forget on camera to wish her all the best with her training which is starting this coming September. I hope you have an amazing experience. And if you're listening to this as an incoming trainee psychologist, I hope that you find the same. It isn't always easy. I hope that you remain pleased,
非常感谢我的嘉宾埃斯特·蒂奥。我在镜头前确实忘记祝愿她今年9月即将开始的培训一切顺利。希望你有一段美妙的体验。如果你正在听这段节目，并且是一名即将入学的心理学学员，我希望你也能有同感。这并不总是容易的。我希望你依然会感到高兴，
that it's a choice that you've made and that you've fought with so hard for. If things change, I'm here. The podcast is always here. It's not just for aspiring psychologists. It's for anyone undertaking a psychology. career at any stage of that career. Obviously, this current episode might have specific relevance for those earlier in their career, but frankly, also, as a qualified psychologist, this was still
因为这是你作出的选择，也是你为之奋斗得如此艰难的选择。如果事情有变，我一直都在。播客也一直都在。它不仅面向有志成为心理学家的人。它面向任何在职业生涯任何阶段从事心理学工作的人。显然，当前这一期节目可能对那些职业生涯较早阶段的人特别有相关性，但坦率地说，作为一个合格的心理学家，这依然是
something that I really needed to be aware of, especially in my line of work. If you'd like to get your hands on the free PDF guide, please do head along to gtps.c.cartra.com forward slash BPS-PS-hyphen guide. The details are in the show notes and in the description and Esther and I would welcome any feedback you have about it. How has this episode been? Has it been useful for you? Has it wet your appetite to go and ask, go and seek your BPS equivalence or has it left you curious about other aspects of the career? We'd love to hear from you. Drop your comments in, drop your questions like this video and if you're on Spotify, you can drop episode specific comments and questions too. If you are listening on Apple Podcasts, please do take a moment to rate and review the show.
我真正需要意识到的事情，尤其是在我所从事的行业中。如果你想获取免费的PDF指南，请前往 gtps.c.cartra.com/BPS-PS-hyphen guide。详细信息在节目简介和描述中，我和埃斯特欢迎你对本期节目提出任何反馈。这一期节目感觉如何？对你有用吗？它是否勾起了你去寻求BPS同等学历认证的兴趣，还是让你对职业的其他方面产生了好奇？我们很想听到你的声音。请留下你的评论，留下你的问题，给这个视频点赞。如果你在Spotify上，你也可以留下针对本期节目的评论和问题。如果你在Apple Podcasts上收听，请花一点时间为节目评分和评论。
And if you'd really like to support the show and the career, please consider leaving me a Google review, which is available if you do a Google search for aspiring psychologist. I should come up. You can click Leave a Review. We did mention the Clinical Psychologist Collective Book in this episode, and you get lovely reviews, and people find it really validating, really rewarding, and really useful at different stages of their career, including applications, including interviews, and then also qualified psychologists have read it so that they can renew their insight into what it's like to be earlier in your career. If you've found this episode helpful, you might
如果您真的很想支持本节目和我的职业发展，请考虑给我写一条谷歌评价。您可以在谷歌上搜索 aspiring psychologist，应该就能找到我，然后点击“写评价”。我们在本期节目中提到了《临床心理学家合集》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书，它收到了许多好评，大家觉得它在职业生涯的不同阶段（包括申请、面试）都非常具有肯定意义、富有成效且极其有用。此外，已取得资格的心理学家也会阅读这本书，以便重新了解职业生涯早期是什么样的。如果您觉得本期节目对您有所帮助，您可能
also find an episode I did with Samuel Chew, interesting, about how to become an UK qualified psychologist as an international student. This is the one to look out for. and if you watch the end of this video it will appear on screen and you can just click go ahead and watch Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton I bought the book the Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications and I'm so glad I did seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get onto the doctorate this year, that's okay.
还会对我和塞缪尔·丘（Samuel Chew）合作的一期节目感兴趣，内容关于国际学生如何成为英国注册心理学家。这就是那期值得关注的节目。如果您观看到本视频的末尾，它将出现在屏幕上，您只需点击即可观看。嗨，我叫艾米丽（Emily）。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士生。我买了《临床心理学家合集》这本书来帮助自己准备第一轮博士申请，我很高兴我这么做了。看到其他人如何反思他们的心路历程真的很有启发，这让我也对自己的经历和技能有了很多思考。它还帮助我摆正了心态，提醒我如果今年没有考上博士也没关系。
I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was. And using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
然而，我认为这本书最意想不到的惊喜，是每个人独特的经历都如此鼓舞人心。每天早上用这些故事来激励自己真是一种享受。我甚至有点舍不得读到最后。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。